lumbus through the revolution in facing
east from Indian country author Daniel
Richter tells the story of the original
Americans through the lives of
Pocahontas Blessed Catherine dake a qui
t'a and Metacom this program from the
Library Company of Philadelphia runs 55
minutes we're very pleased to be
presenting Daniel K Richter as our
speaker this evening dan is fairly new
to Philadelphia having arrived just a
little over two years ago from Dickinson
college to become a professor of history
at Penn and the director of the McNeil
Center for early American Studies Dan's
going to be speaking tonight about the
second book that he's written that deals
with Native Americans in the colonial
and early national period of our history
his first book which was called the
ordeal of the longhouse the peoples of
the Iroquois League in the era of
European colonization came out in 1992
and was based on Dan's Columbia
University doctoral dissertation and it
won both the Ray Allen Allen Billington
prize and the Frederick Jackson Turner
award from the organization of American
Historians his new book that we're going
to be hearing about this evening facing
east from Indian country a native
history of early America practically
turns our view of the nation's early
history on its head in it Dan explores
more than 300 years of Indian white
relations east of the Mississippi from
the turn of the 16th century through the
subjugation of the native people during
the Jacksonian era and he does this from
the point of view of the Indians
themselves his perspective is always
facing east contemplating how Indians
responded to the white influence and
presence in their lands and it is not a
simple story of the in electable
westward expansion of whites and the
disappearance of Indians and their
displacement rather it's a story of
mutual interaction and interchange as
both Indians and whites dealt with the
powerful forces that the arrival of the
whites unleashed his concern is
particularly with the economic and
environmental and biological dimensions
of that interchange and the ways in
which the Indians over time adapted to
the white presence and sought to
maintain their integrity both as in
you'll tribes and as a greater people
the year 1763 looms large in the story
when the British virtually eliminated
the French from the continent and also
thereby eliminated the ability of the
Indians to play a balance of power
politics and you know playing off one
Empire against the other and the
aftermath of the American Revolution was
another watershed for it removed the
British themselves from the equation and
gave the new nation a virtual carte wash
to drive the Indians from its midst this
process reached its sanguinary
culmination in the removals of the
Jacksonian Europe damn does a masterful
job of viewing this long and tortured
history through an Indian prism and he
allows us to see how this tragedy played
out to those who were looking east so
I'm very pleased to present
Daniel Richter this evening
thanks John for that wonderful
introduction and thanks for everyone for
being here tonight it's I don't quite
know what to make of such a big crowd on
this occasion now I think particularly
John and Jim Green on behalf of the
library company and David McGee Hanson
and Shan Holt who's here somewhere on
behalf of HSP for organizing this event
library company in HSP are just two of
the greatest places in the world two of
my favorite places to be and I can't
think of any place I'd rather be tonight
talking about this book as some of you
many of you know the McNeil Center for
early American Studies has a sort of
traveling seminar that moves all over
the area and we frequently meet here at
the library company although usually in
the other room over here where you had
your refreshments and the speaker there
usually faces east and so it's a little
disorienting to be here facing south but
I'll try to deal with that anyway I'm
not quite sure what to do in an event
like this a summary of the book seems a
little redundant for those who've
already read it perhaps
counterproductive for those who haven't
and besides I think John did is a better
job than I could have summing up the
book in his introduction and furthermore
I think facing east at least from my
perspective probably this close to it is
a little hard to summarize in a few
words and so I I don't think I'm gonna
try to do that tonight a reading seems a
bit literary and a bit heavy I don't
think I'm gonna try anything dramatic
and I don't even have a copy of the book
with me so you're spared that I'm not
much one for true confessions of stories
of my own life and how I came to be here
so I'm not gonna do that either although
I do assure you I don't have any
skeletons I know about in my closet I've
never claimed well fought in Vietnam I
think all the words in the book that
aren't my own are in quotation marks so
I hope that there's no confessions in
order when I asked John and David what I
should do they weren't much help either
they talked a lot about time
and I think they encouraged me to keep
this down to three or four hours so I'll
try to do my best but the one hint they
did give was that maybe I could say a
few things about how I came to write the
book and where it sort of fits in the
broader scheme of things so I think I'll
start with that and along the way try to
explain a little bit about what I mean
by facing east and some of the things I
hope that I've been able to do in the in
this book the origins of this book are
not at all straightforward and one of
the things I've actually been trying to
figure out over the last couple of days
is how I did come to write this book and
I think the first thing that suddenly
occurred to me maybe this is a little
bit self revelatory I never seem to be
able to write the books I set out to
write and I think it's started when I
went to graduate school to study
Puritans and and and wound up doing this
whole other thing the book that became
the ordeal the longhouse started out to
be a study of the New York frontier
during the American Revolution and I was
going to sort of do this complicated
multi-ethnic analysis of why different
groups chose the path they did during
the Revolution I figured the Indian
stuff had already been done then I just
read a few books and kind of plug that
in and I discovered it hadn't been done
and I kind of got focused on
particularly the Six Nations Iroquois
and then I kept moving backwards in time
and the book that ultimately I wrote
started literally with creation and
never got past seventeen thirty so I
never got to the American Revolution
well that's a bit of a background and
after that book came out I entered a
phase of not quite knowing what to do
next
stumbled into a couple of things
particularly by way of some things
friends and colleagues had asked me to
do among them was a historiographical
essay on Native Americans in
Pennsylvania and I wrote that and Kane's
conclusion that there was a huge
historiographical black hole and that
that historical graphical black hole was
the years after the American Revolution
we have a lot of very important stuff
seemed to be going on and almost no one
had written about it so I set off to do
a project about Pennsylvanians and
Native Americans after the American
Revolution and I had a year's leave in
the early 90s spent much
that year in Philadelphia spent much of
the time I was on that leave in the
wonderful old manuscript reading room
next door at the HSP many of you
remember what a great place that was to
work and collected a huge number of
notes did a lot of work on that project
and I really thought I was gonna write
about that and then the next thing I
knew other things happened and I got
this invitation to write a sort of
classroom supplemental reading book you
know about Native Americans in the
colonial period
I thought that'll be easy I can knock
that off and you know a year or two I
can kind of write this quick 200 pager
and and get it out of the way and do
that and then get back and really figure
out what I wanted to do about the other
project so I signed a contract to do
what was supposed to be a pretty
straightforward narrative history of
Native Americans in colonial times
depending on defining what colonial
meant was a sort of open-ended issue
there so I was supposed to be doing that
the next thing I knew I'd been invited
to a sort of celebration for my graduate
school advisor Alden Vaughan who was
retiring in the early 1990s and instead
of a sort of standard operation of
having people give serious scholarly
papers and produce a Festschrift of
essays that no one would ever read and
publishers would never publish someone
got the bright idea that we should have
a sort of workshop for high school
teachers and that all of us who were
students of Alden Vaughn should come in
and talk about our particular
specialties and how they might inform
high school teachers curricula as they
taught American history one of the neat
things about Alden was that he would let
you do anything which of course is why I
was able to change my topic in midstream
and so we had this wonderfully diverse
group of people who had studying all
sorts of different aspects of early
American history and we came and had a
really nice couple of days in Worcester
Massachusetts talking to these high
school teachers and sort of trying to
convince them that what we were doing
was a neat way to look at early American
history and so in doing that I found
myself saying well you know what how do
you teach early American history and I
came up with this phrase that I didn't
quite I didn't quite know what the
phrase meant but I said you should face
East and you should not sort of maybe
think about a ways of having your
students not sort of stand on the deck
of the Mayflower or the Susan constant
or something and follow people as they
come from Europe to the wilderness of
America or perhaps come to Europe to
Native America fall on their knees and
kill some people and then go about the
real story but rather that me that's
kind of that's what I call a westward
facing history the the storyline runs
from Europe to North America the real
characters are the are the Europeans and
it's a story that in a sense makes North
American history an adjunct to European
history and inevitably I think makes
Native Americans either irrelevant or
simply victims of a juggernaut that is
rolling westward okay so I said let's
try facing east let's try to see if we
can find ways to get students to think
about American history that is rooted in
this continent here that tries to
develop story lines that don't face West
from Europe but face east from North
America and I said try to imagine you
know your students as reporters and
you're gonna sort of assign them to the
deadbeat I think I actually used that
phrase and sort of send them into the
past to try to imagine how American
history white look if you stood in North
America and Indian country and looked
over the shoulder of an algonquian woman
hoeing her cornfield instead of standing
on the deck of the Mayflower and looking
West and that sounded very nifty at the
time
and I tried to explain in particular
that I meant something significant by
saying standing over the shoulder of the
Algonquian woman hoeing her cornfield
because I didn't think it was possible
for us to get inside that woman's head
and see things through her eyes and I
still think that as they sort of turn of
the 21st century middle-aged white guy
there's no way that I could get inside
the heads of Native Americans 300 years
ago but rather the idea is to stand in
Indian country try to develop ways of
thinking about Native American history
in general that that imagine the story
being told from this place and from a
place that starts as Indian country and
put Indians as much as possible it's
center stage in the stories so that's
what I tried to convince those high
school teachers of they seem to
appreciate it and then went back
presumably to teaching things the way
they always did because it was totally
unlike imagine how this was supposed to
work I went home and tried to sit down
to write this boring straightforward 200
page book about Native American history
and just kept hitting a blank wall I
spent as several of my summers have been
over the years staring at a computer
screen and going off to do woodworking
projects at home you know coming back to
stare at the computer screen some more I
tried and tried to write the chapter
that was supposed to start somewhere at
the Bering Straits and get us some get
us to 1492 in one chapter and then let
the real story start and nothing was
coming out and all the time I kept
thinking well I got to face East and I
kept thinking about that Algonquin woman
ho in her cornfield who just kept living
in my head somewhere and so the next
thing I knew I was writing a first draft
of what became the chapter one of facing
East which really was initially this
effort to try to be a reporter standing
in Indian country in the 16th century
and so what I did in there was trying to
look at the various texts particularly
focusing on the DeSoto expedition and
Cartier's visits to the st. Lawrence
Valley and try to imagine what that
might have looked like if we were
standing there watching it I'm trying to
figure out how you could read those
documents to make that happen I had a
lot of fun with it and I really it was
it was
about the time that John D Moses book
the unredeemed captive came out where he
suddenly made it possible to make stuff
up as a legitimate I mean that in a
respectful way as a way of trying to
recapture something about the past and
so I felt liberated to make some stuff
up here not you know footnoting
everything and making sure that was all
somehow rooted in the documents but
really sort of imagining being there and
what it might have looked like if we
could be there and I also discovered
that perhaps this was an interesting way
to think about how Native Americans
discovered Europe because of course
their experience was really largely
about imagining where these people and
things came from and so I sort of
developed what I thought was kind of a
fun exercise in facing east and I said
this is what it's all about and I gave
the paper a couple of places one of them
back to Philadelphia I keep getting
dragged back to Philadelphia this is
another theme I don't set out what I
want to do and do what I set out to do
when I come back to Philadelphia
why can't Philadelphia and gave gave
this paper at one of Michael Zucker
man's wonderful little evening soirees
that many of you know about and people
seem to appreciate okay I'm really onto
something here so then I sent this draft
off to my good friend Jim Merrill and if
you don't know Jim Merrill he is a
wonderful historian of early America has
written a couple of the stunning books
about Native American history and he
said yeah this is pretty neat but what
are you gonna do next are you gonna have
your readers just running around
backwards all over the continent facing
east you know okay okay we've run around
for a while the sixteenth Center now
we're gonna run around facing backwards
and from here there and everywhere and I
thought yeah Jim you're right this is
just not gonna be able to sustain this
for an entire book so I went into
another slough of despond went off built
some more bookcases and did some more um
woodworking at home and began to rethink
well you know if I do this maybe the
real point is trying to explore
different ways of facing east and
thinking about how this metaphor might
work itself out in ways that are not
quite so straightforward as imagining
yourself on the scene but different ways
of trying to make stories work that
recapture something of of a history of
Native America so then I thought well
okay let's try to think about different
chapters each of which does this and you
know how can you face east in different
ways
along about that time I wrote to my
editor for the book I had a contract for
and said I think what I'm writing is
probably not what you're looking for and
he said yeah it's not what we're looking
for so we broke the contract and I
thought okay now this is really neat I
can write the book I want to write I
don't have to cover stuff anymore you
know I can leave things out so I started
playing with this I thought well okay
how can we face east and one way we can
do this is as as John said to not just
have this kind of imagination as our
device but to look at radically
different ways of putting stories
together and so one of the ways I tried
to do that was in what became the second
chapter of the book which is to look at
the material forces and in particular I
I hope the contrast is kind of
interesting as you go from this kind of
imagined being there kind of chapter
into one that plunges you right into
microbes and material goods and
ecological change and sort of looking at
the continent itself and how it's
changing as a way of facing East became
the next thing I did and then I said
well you know it's all about telling
stories and so let's tell some stories
and so I took three familiar life
stories or at least sent me familiar
life stories or at least stories that
were familiar to some people and those
stories were the stories of Pocahontas
gotta read Dickens witih
the will probably the first Native
American Saint and King Philip and said
well let's just try to turn these
stories upside down and say what might
they really be if we could try to tell
them as Indian history as opposed to
European history and I hope that as I
was trying to write that I wasn't saying
this is the straight poop on these
people there's there are various ways to
look at it but let's just try to save
what fragmentary information we have
might help us see them as as emblematic
of some larger forces that were going on
the 17th century in in North America so
I finally thought I was on a roll the
next chapter was going to be one that
really got back to I think the original
idea which was writing something for
undergraduates how do you read documents
was gonna be the theme the next one and
so I looked at the
particularly a set of texts that were
extremely problematic words that were
written down by Europeans through which
presumably some glimmering of a native
voice came through
if voices can glimmer some echo of a
native voice came through and so I kind
of tried to sort of walk through an
effort to read those things and then I
hit another brick wall because I'd run
out of ways to face East okay
imagine material forces life stories how
do you read documents and then the other
course the thing that was happening was
as I began to move forward through time
and I did figure out how I could make
these things kind of work
chronologically that was getting to a
period when we knew a whole lot more
about the actual stuff and that the real
problem was less trying to bridge the
gaps in the documents and figure out how
we could reconstruct something of of
native experiences and more how
particularly as you get into the 18th
century which is another
historiographical black hole despite the
fact that there are millions of books
written on the 18th century in general
american historians have not known how
to deal with the 18th century no quite
apart from Native American history you
know people get off those ships and they
do all sorts of neat things in the 17th
century they hang some witches they you
know they do their Puritan thing
Puritanism declines and then you have
this sort of boring period when I don't
know people are living in Williamsburg
and so and then and then of course there
was the problem of trying to well do i
or do I not try to deal with the
American Revolution and and try to make
something of Native American experiences
there so I struggle to struggle with
that but I think ultimately what I tried
to do was write something that looks a
little more like a straightforward
narrative and I do sort of move through
the 18th century and into chapters and
then have a chapter set of a long
chapter on the long American Revolution
starting in 1763 and ending in about
1830 but really trying to say that those
are also ways of facing East trying to
kind of invert narratives or look at
ways of telling stories that thumb that
might
bus keep native-americans center stage
and maybe even tell us something that we
didn't think we knew or perhaps had only
glimpsed about early American history so
what I did for the eighteenth-century
chapter to try to get us out of the
living in Williamsburg mode was to try
to apply a paradigm that historians have
been using a lot for the 18th century in
recent years and that is a so think
about the Atlantic world and the
Imperial system and how Native Americans
might have fit into that and one of the
things I hope that that chapter tries to
do is you know recapture and what looks
like a period when nothing much is
happening a way of seeing Native
Americans as real actors and adapting to
any imperial system and carving out for
themselves in the imperial world a sort
of new native North America so I did
that and then the Revolution chapter as
as John suggested focuses particularly
on 1763 but tries to sort of see the
year 1763 I think as I kind of lens
through which to watch everything that
would happen later in particular I focus
in that chapter on two really
cataclysmic events of that year what's
usually referred to as Pontiacs
rebellion that's a shorthand term for a
very complicated event and another
complicated term phrase is the Paxton
boys affair and kind of looking at both
of those as articulations of a kind of
new and stark vision one on the Native
American side and one on the Euro
American side of continent in which
Europeans and Indians no longer could
imagine living together and I try to
look at these two ideologies which by no
means are shared by everybody on either
side of what suddenly became in 1763 a
frontier a line instead of a messy
situation of a lot of people and try to
sort of see if we can capture something
about how those ideas first articulated
in 1763 worked themselves out over the
next few years and helped us understand
something about the nature of the United
States that replace
in many respects Indian country in in
that period so that's what I thought I
did or what I hope I thought I did and
this book has evolved in a way that I
hadn't quite anticipated and in
particular I've always thought that
their hope that the book would be just
as much about how to write this kind of
history as it was about the history
itself in fact I'm not even sure it is
about that history it's more about
trying to get us to think about things
in ways that you know try to follow up
on that metaphor of a native history
that's rooted in this continent but one
that doesn't pretend really very often
at least doesn't pretend to actually see
things through native eyes or to
recapture in any kind of definitive way
Native American experiences but does try
to keep Native Americans center stage
and to see a story that that is rooted
in this continent and it's long history
before Europeans arrived but also just
as much as that to try to give his ways
of thinking about a real history for
Native Americans in that long period and
what I mean by a real history for Native
Americans is finding a way to think
about periodization trying to think
about a change trying to think about
Native Americans as human beings who
change and adapt and live in time and
don't inhabit some kind of static
timeless paradise that was disrupted by
Europeans and then spend the rest of
their time trying to recapture that but
rather change adapt struggle
live in history and our people who who
move through time in in ways that we can
often only glimpse but I hope some of
the ways that I've tried to lay this out
in the book will be be useful in helping
us to to move that along so that's what
I hope I did I could continue to talk
about this but I won't except to say
that I did close the book with an
epilogue that looks at very closely
the work of an early 19th century
fascinating figure William APUs who
often signed his name William APUs a
Pequot a Native American author in the
1830s whose significance was I think
first brought to our attention by Barry
O'Connell ah a student of American
literature who wrote a variety of works
he was he was a Methodist preacher he
was a political activist he was an
author and memoirist and he was in many
respects a pretty good historian too and
so I look in particular at a speech he
gave in the 1830s called a eulogy on
King Phillip which looks back at some of
the things that are discussed earlier in
the book and also I think epitomized in
some ways what what I mean by facing
east
William APIs himself trying to recapture
something of a Native American past and
trying to tell stories that
self-consciously contradicted many of
the the myths and the standard histories
of his own day so I said I wasn't gonna
summarize the book but that's what I
wound up doing I hope I've said
something that's at least interesting if
not provocative and would welcome
questions and comments and anything else
you might have
see I think we have a microphone that is
traveling around the room it looks more
like a feather duster to me making
process between the Native Americans and
the colonists a means of gaining entry
to the mentality and perspective of the
Native Americans well one of the things
I do in in the book is actually look
fairly closely at some of the minutes of
treaty negotiations right and particular
try to follow up on what they tell us
about what Native Americans thought was
happening at those events which is not
necessarily what Europeans thought was
happening and not necessarily perhaps
what we even mean by tree much of that
has to do with suppose the view that a
treaty is not so much about a deal or a
particular set of arrangements or a
particular set of agreements and in fact
from a native perspective maybe signing
a document would be one of the least
significant parts or at least one of
only many parts in the process that
really treaties are about the process of
having a treaty
it's about affirming in a very public
and participatory way on an ongoing
relationship between two peoples and has
to do with ceremonial ritual it has to
do with making sure that lots of people
are present one of the things of course
always dismays European governors is the
expense and the time and the delays that
are involved with all these people
descending on Albany OR Williamsburg or
Philadelphia or whatever and it's
important that they're all there you
can't have sort of deals made in
smoke-filled longhouses you've got to
the whole point is the participatory act
of enacting the relationship telling the
stories of the relationship often very
formalized ways having a kind of
metaphor that explains what each side is
supposed to be doing for each other
explaining the benefits of the
relationship to each other the language
that was often used to describe this was
brightening the chain of Covenant right
and chains get rusty they have to be
brightened you've got to have treaties
over and over again it's not a one-time
time deal and all this is deeply
reflective of I think not just Native
American world views but Native American
politics in the way that the political
systems of Native Americans worked
another thing that it tells us
particulars we look in the 18th century
is it helps us understand something
about how the many diverse native
cultures of eastern North America were
actually becoming something we can call
Indian by sharing these political
rituals by sharing the participation of
treaty making by sharing in interesting
ways through European powers a set of
common experiences and in common rituals
and and procedures that is an
interesting insight into again thinking
about change over time and how people
come to have a sense of themselves as as
being Native Americans in as well as
being Cherokees or Susquehanna Hawks
we'll make our way to the back of the
Fed better if the British should won the
American Revolution and have they fed
better in Canada than in the United
States short answer is no they would
have fared differently I think actually
a Greg Dowd who's another great great
contemporary historian of these issues
and I have been sort of fighting about
this issue and he seems to be on a
crusade to prove that things would have
been even worse had the British stayed
in control
what is interesting though is that I
think in 1763 as the British were trying
to figure out what to do with this
enormous new empire they had and trying
to figure out what to do with the
continent that suddenly in theory at
least belonged to them and from which
the French had been expelled and the
Spanish were much smaller player than
they had been before I was to imagine
ways of really sort of incorporating
Native Americans into that Empire in a
way that would have made them subjects
would have made them inferior people and
would not necessarily have been pleasant
but would I think significantly have
envisioned Native Americans as part of
the Empire right and one of the ideas I
put forward in the book which I keep
waiting for someone to say is terribly
wrong is that this was one of the things
that deeply bothered many British
Americans of European ancestry the idea
that the British government could
actually be imagining Native Americans
having rights and having to be protected
by the government and being part of the
future of the continent in ways that you
know I'm not saying that somebody
sitting in Whitehall really had thought
this through
but they really are sort of acting in
ways that actually are much more
traditionally imperialistic I mean
what's the point of having an empire if
you don't conquer people and incorporate
them right and it's a very very
different vision I think that from 1763
on many euro Americans are developing of
a continent that is entirely in which
the native population is entirely
replaced by by Europeans and Indians
have no place in that
continent in fact in some of the more
bizarre fantasies of people in the early
19th century white people become the new
Indians right they they become the
Americans they join fraternal
organizations that have pseudo Indian
rituals they even have clubs with names
like the improved order of red men you
know that that literally displace the
native population and see Noah Noah
space in that continent for them so I'm
I'm would argue that had the British
remain in control of course that's a big
if the experience would have been vastly
different not necessarily better but
perhaps something a little more
resembling India than the United States
yes in the back man you made that
observation because it it kind of falls
in line with what I've been thinking
listening to you the concept that that
the British could have been might have
been could whatever better worse
probably worse how much worse could it
possibly have been then then the
development of you know of the concept
of westward expansion and manifest
destiny I mean hell wiping out that you
know the the [ __ ] population the only
good Indian is a dead Indian mentality I
don't think the British could ever have
created a Commonwealth in which they
said the only good Indian and we're
talking New Delhi Indian is a dead
Indian
I mean maybe after that that rebellion
but the the Greece and all that madness
oh what was that what was that the 1837
or whatever but but I see here the pot
and you talk about 18 1763 being being
what you call the excuse me the seminal
yeah the formative year
of 1763 and in Pontiacs dream of the of
the the Delaware prophet he says this
land where you dwell I have made for you
and not for others
whence come it that ye permit the whites
upon your lands can you not live without
them and then further down that it says
but if you are not evil as your you
could surely do without them you could
live as you did before knowing them and
this is a concept that if I bought I
when I was a kid I always oh well well
why did the Indians you know why did the
Indians embrace and allow you know be
the the European the European presence
and and and and and subsequent you know
dominance and it kind of makes me wonder
that listening to you it all becomes
very clear listening to you which I
don't know if that's fortunate or
unfortunate but but when it says to is
that there was some practical that it
was some almost of divine dispensation
where in the America is created because
of the Native American response to the
year to the European first British that
American presence I don't know if
there's a question of all this but maybe
what it says is that I've come to see it
better
having listened to you and just casually
leaf through your book that the same way
that there was a book written about the
South the Incan and my in the South
American Indian response to the Spanish
conquistadors for some reason or other
it all becomes much clearer listening to
you
that what what the the American
experience these are the Native
Americans post-revolution and into the
you know the period of westward
expansion that that mindset there's a
mindset there there sometimes it's often
difficult to grasp but I think that in
your looking at the Native American
response one sees better the European /
American side of that equation and I
just wanted to say thank you for that
thank you I wanted to hear a little bit
one of the things that I found the most
provocative about the book is the way
that you sort of posit as a creative and
imaginative endeavor it's very easy in
sort of the popular public opinion of
the way history is done sort of
pigeonhole us as social scientists
searching for truth and compiling lists
of dates and names and as many
practicing historians know that's not
what we spend her time doing but this
idea of positing a creative and an
imaginative way of getting not inside
the minds of people obviously as you
crazy caution but of thinking about the
world in different ways that are that
are revealing in ways that you don't get
in just approaching head-on a document
that's handed to you in an archive and I
just like to hear it more about what you
what you think about that the process
and that the possibilities for thinking
about history that way well I think this
goes back to my initial sort of teaching
aim for the book to that I really do
hope that it's all about doing history
and it's been one of the things that's
been very interesting I had I had real
trouble selling this manuscript to
anyone particularly early on when it was
really all focused on method and I keep
getting these nice rejection letters
that's very interesting you know and but
I think we don't really want a book
about doing history we want a book that
is the history you know and so if you
would really write us something that
does what
to say people ought to do then that
would be fine but we just sort of want
to know what the real story is and
because I kept sort of things well and
that's not the point you know the point
is to think about how the stories are
put together and what we can learn from
that and this is not going to be doing
this in fact I decided not to say this
but I'm gonna say it anyway
one of the early reviews was in the Los
Angeles Times a month or so ago by a
person I don't know and I don't know
whether and if you know him either in
fact I repressed his name I'm looking
for the quote which I have here in my
Anthony day who I guess writes a lot of
reviews for Los Angeles Times and his
his review focuses on my use of the word
narrative all the time I always put some
quotes idea thinking about stories of
the past and then he concludes a for all
Richter's good will towards the Indians
and his earnest effort to imagine a
different narrative it is hard to
conceive of a history much different
from that which occurred given the
energy skills a number of the invaders
the Indians never had a chance and well
I say well okay
that may be the big picture but I don't
think that's what my book is about it's
really about trying to discover
something about how people live through
this experience of and how in fact while
maybe in the long run we might conclude
they didn't have a chance
300 years is a long time not to have a
chance I think among other things and so
that really it was sort of thinking
about it of course the story didn't turn
out any differently this is like like
the question about the British Empire
and I reminds me actually of Saturday
Night Live used to have these routines
of historians sitting around doing what
if and I think there was one about what
if Eleanor Roosevelt could fly this
whole thing about world war two turned
out there you know of course it didn't
turn out differently than it did but
that doesn't mean that we can't learn
something from trying to experience
understand something about the
experiences of people that otherwise
might just appear to be mere victims of
the process
I've got a kind of double-layer question
and and one is is that any oral Indian
tradition about the Revolutionary period
in the northeast and the other one is
that in literature which is my field
there are plenty of african-americans
and Caribbeans who theorized or who
produce literature and who are
extensively revives in the way it's both
flooded and written and I was wondering
if there was anything analogous going on
in history in relation to Amerindian
groups in the United States certainly
others those are two big questions
fairly multi-layered but big ones yes
there are there are oral traditions
about the revolution and I guess one
that well two that are when here's quite
a bit about today are um one is the
story of how Native Americans brought
food to George Washington Valley Forge
which may or may not be accurate but I
think it's a it's an effort to say
something about the relationship also of
course the repeated story that we hear
that somehow other the US Constitution
was based on the Iroquois League of the
Holy Shoni all of which are I think real
efforts to interesting efforts in some
ways to face east to kind of make Native
American experience is central to the
American experience there are also
stories that are not well documented to
say the least from a European social
science standpoint and perhaps like many
oral stories tell us much more about
people's place in history as they
perceive it and the stuff out there and
that makes it just as interesting and
just as important in some ways as for
your second question about how native
understandings of have or have not
reshaped scholarly understanding someone
if I track the second question
and Caribbeans who are and maybe more so
in the Caribbean where they're really
theorizing about about literature and
about the production of literature so
they're creating a whole new what is the
whole new theory and and different types
of work of being done I'm it's true of
African Americans as well and I was
wondering if there's anything analogous
in relation to history and Amerindians
is there any of that kind of developed
maybe philosophical or theoretical
critique of focused very clearly on a
critique of of Western social science
understandings and an attempt to inform
our understandings of history in general
I think with with what are with what are
described as Native Americans
understandings of time and much of the
literature although also focuses on a
contrast or sometimes or I think largely
over drawn between what is described as
a Native American time that is circular
and in a sense not linear and not really
history as Westerners understand it that
very frequently I think gets gets all
wrapped up in a lot of contemporary
issues about identity and in ways that
it's it's hard to figure out how to
operationalize this is then as a
historical phenomenon it is also
interesting that in terms of world
traditions the
at least the past of 200 years ago is
with the exception of a couple of the
things I just mentioned is remarkably on
remembered in at least in terms of
events in in native traditions which
tells us also something I think about
the function of those native traditions
which are tend to be about origins tend
to be about identity tend to be about
who people are and often are indeed not
particularly focused on the kinds of
questions that Western academic
historian types are interested in since
you were trying to get in it interpret
in my discussion with modern Indians
people have Indian blood in them I find
that I couldn't get to first base trying
to to discuss things with him to get a
logical conclusion he didn't think like
I did it was just and every time I
pinned him down they slipped off and
went somewhere else and just very
mercurial did you you must have got some
view of the Indian mind well I think the
first thing I would say is that I'm
really hesitant to say there's anything
like the Indian mind and I think there
is I think it might be accurate to say
that in the keep having to remind myself
it's the 21st century that there may be
something today that does resemble a a
Native American way of talking about the
world okay but it is it's also a product
of history and a product of dialogue
with Westerners and often is quite
self-consciously designed to put forward
a point of view that is that is
non-western right in terms of
understanding Native American minds
three centuries ago four centuries ago
it's it's a very tough thing we don't we
have very few hints of
the way people really express their
world much of what we do have to go on
involves records by people like
missionaries and diplomats in situations
where Native Americans had every reason
often not to speak their minds plainly
many of the people I write about spoke
languages which are no longer spoken
related languages still exist but you
know we don't we don't have access to to
those minds in the way that we do for
European Americans although I also think
we often delude ourselves how much we
can get inside the heads of of European
Americans 300 years ago as well that's
probably why I stopped studying Puritans
because we thought we knew what the
Puritan mind was - I guess not at all
about how useful these histories and
perspectives and narratives would be to
contemporary Native Americans in schools
or or in defining account an ongoing
relationship with American life I've
thought about that a lot and I think I
keep coming back to the idea that it
it's not for me to tell Native Americans
what's useful to them I hope that I'm
saying something that will be useful but
I would be satisfied if I get your
American types and African American
types to see something in this
we tend to think a lot about Native
Americans and Europeans as two separate
categories but in a lot of context those
boundaries could be pretty fluid I'm
wondering among the groups that you
studied was the option for individuals
to pass or for groups to be assimilated
there and that any groups choose to go
that route or did individuals choose to
go that route well I suppose a couple of
things there one is I really want to get
back to my idea of Native Americans in
history and distressing change because
some I think in many respects it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense to talk about
either Native Americans or
euro-americans before sometime in the
18th century I probably made it too
simple by saying it's July 1st 1763 when
that happens but that there is a there's
a kind of messiness to the cultural and
social map before that period that makes
generalizations either about your
Americans or Native Americans not very
useful
people lived on a continent that was
controlled by lots of different powers
some of them native some of them
Europeans there were three different
European powers there the British Empire
itself is composed of this messy batch
of often squabbling colonies an
Americans are all these different groups
which are by the 18th century in
particular amalgamations of survivors of
epidemics and Wars and all sorts of
things that create what I sometimes
refer to as the real American melting
pot is in Native American communities
and it really is I think something does
get clarified when the European Imperial
picture changes when that competition on
which Native American groups have based
much of their political and economic and
indeed in some respects cultural
survival in the 18th century disappears
when only one Empire faces what now
suddenly does appear to people on both
sides as Indians I think that's part of
what Pontiacs message is that you know
realizing that we are all Indians right
and they are all Europeans or at least
the British are all Europeans maybe the
French are from something too
but the but it's part of the struggle to
kind of figure out a modern or what
looks like a distressingly modern set of
racial categories that that separates
these groups and certainly one of the
things that motivates the rage of both
the Paxton boys and Pontiac I think is
the fact that people cross those
boundaries that those movements are
directed I think just as much at euro
Americans who think on the Paxton boys
side that you're Americans who think
that Native Americans and European
Americans can live together and on
Pontiac side at Native Americans who
think the two sides can live together
and that people can cross and there's a
way of mixing they're both trying to put
forward I think a kind of vision of
abetik cleansing and ethnic purity that
is really startlingly new and and and
ugly I think other groups that kind of
had us developing sense of of Rage
toward Indians and but what about the
Quakers I mean what did Indians what did
Native Americans in Pennsylvania think
about Quakers if there were any good
guys I suppose they tended to see
Quakers as good guys in particular I
think one of the things that is
important is there that both Quakers and
Native Americans tended to develop a
very early on a kind of mythology of
William Penn and what he stood for um
you know owned us the great thumb the
great peacemaker and and and all that
becomes a kind of dialogue in which each
side is trying to use that image of what
Quakers are supposed to be and how
they're supposed to act towards the
Native Americans as a important part of
that relationship but certainly if if
there are people who are struggling
towards some vision trying to maintain
some vision of a coexistence in the 18th
century it is it is the Quakers and
that's one reason I think they get
slammed and Pennsylvania politics during
the American Revolution
two quick comments and two quick
questions though the answers may not be
quick I think what first comment that
you do a wonderful job of drawing on the
different disciplines with which history
interacts to try to recover and uncover
a pattern trajectory complexity question
there you mention euro Americans a lot
you don't mention Africans or African
Americans even though you're facing
south and how does that complicate the
story the second observation observation
is that the archaeological record is
incredibly rich not always well sifted
and not well generalized from but
incredibly rich and in in as reflected
in detailed studies of site after site
after site how much of your story would
be different if you were drawing more on
the archaeological record than you are
and what might be done in a companion
piece that did that I will certainly do
a lot more with material culture in
general and I think it was well part of
that liberating moment of not having to
say everything about early American
history that led me to not write the
book I set out to write I was part of
that I make some choices and I did some
things in particular I think my choice
to stress different methods and
different chapters meant that certain
kinds of evidence didn't get stressed at
bat points when they could have been
very useful certainly understanding the
place of Native Americans in the
Imperial world you can't understand
apart from the empire of goods and the
way in which European material artifacts
in 18th century became absolutely
central to not just the economies but in
many respects the cultural identities of
Native Americans and ways that only in
many respects increased their cultural
distance from Europeans at the same time
they incorporated them in in the your
in economic world okay so I certainly
could have done a lot more with with
archeology and that is one of the things
I decided to leave out another thing I
certainly could have done a lot more
with with african-americans but one of
the striking things about that that you
know does come up over and over again
particularly I think after about the
1670s is that one small Native Americans
do get the glimmering that in in a world
that really would be run by Europeans
their situation would be much like that
of African Americans Pontiacs teacher
Nealon at really a try racial view of
the world and part of his part of the
argument of these Native American
prophets as Greg Dowd has nicely pointed
out is that the Creator put people on
different continents and gave them
different gifts and that's where the
Creator wanted them to stay and in
particular in a particular kind of
ethnocentric view of this the Creator
clearly made Native Americans first and
place them in North America made
Africans second place them in Africa and
only third as an afterthought created
Europeans and also because I suppose
because of some limitation in Europeans
they had to have a book to tell them how
to live as opposed to everyone else so
certainly I think that that has to be a
big part of the story and one of the
many things that they got left out
thank you so much I thank you all for
coming and I believe we do still have a
couple of books left for sale if anyone
would like to pick one up and ask Dan to
inscribe it good night thanks Daniel
Richter is currently a history professor
and director of the McNeil Center for
early American Studies at the University
of Pennsylvania facing east from Indian
country as published by Harvard
University Press visit hup harvard.edu
to get more information